It's been two years and I finally saved
up enough money to build my perfect
gaming PC. I am ready for a 5070 Ti.
Wait a minute. No, it's not on Amazon.
Wait, out out of stock? A calculator? I
don't want a calculator. I want a 5070
Ti. Are you looking for GPUs? Cuz I
might have one for you. Here you go.
What is this? That is an RX970 XT. It's
going to be just like a 570Ti in stock
and cheaper. In stock? Well, maybe.
We'll tell you about that whole story
after we're from today's sponsor. Dude,
Jackson, I just found a crazy deal on a
GPU. Oh, sweet. What is it? It's a 4070
on Amazon. It's only $1,200. Wait, what?
Yeah, it's also refurbished and sold by
Lucky Boy 3D Star Information Technology
Services. It It seems like a pretty good
deal. Number one, you're fired. Number
two, why are you not shopping at
Jawa.gg? Jawa.gg is one of the best
marketplaces for buying and selling PC
hardware, laptops, peripherals, and even
custom gaming PCs. Whenever we plan out
our PC builds, we always take a peek at
Jawa and hunt for the deals that make
our builds possible. Their component
section is always packed full of
listings, and it's easy to find some
insane prices. And in case you're in the
market for a pre-built, they have a ton
of amazing options aesthetically and
performance-wise for the price, like
this RTX 3070 and Ryzen 5600X gaming PC
for just $900. If you want to keep your
job and save money, do what I should
have done and shop on jaw.gg today. And
be sure to use code toasty10 to save 10%
off your order up to $10. Now, let's get
back to that video. Ladies and
gentlemen, on our table with us here, we
have the brand new AMD RX970 coming in
at 550, and we have the RX97 XT coming
in at 600 bucks. Now, obviously, this is
launch day when you're watching this, so
hopefully availability is better. AMD
has made some claims that availability
should be pretty solid for this GPU
launch, especially for those desperate
for a graphics card right now. But
today, we're going to do a little bit of
a versus video. We're going to take the
top dog, the 9070 XT, which is only $50
more than the 9070 nonXT, and run them
through a bunch of benchmarks that we
like to play and you guys like to play
at home to see if the $50 is actually
worth it. So, for the 9070 XT, we have
16 gigs of VR. SGDDR6, we have RDNA4
technology. Another cool feature is we
have 64 compute units, and we now have
display port 2.1A. Now, with the 9070,
we go into 56 compute units, which will
be interesting to see in the real world
what the difference is between
performance of 64 versus 56 and to see
if that $50 price difference is worth
it. But the VRAM is the same, 16 gigs of
GDDR6 VRAM. And one cool thing as well,
because we really like power efficiency
when it comes to our graphics cards, the
9070 XT requires a 750 watt power supply
with a max power draw theoretically of
over 300 watts, just slightly over 300
watts, while you actually save a 100
watts going with the 9070 nonXT, which
would be pretty cool for more power
efficient systems. But what is the
performance difference like? We're going
to talk about it after we tell you about
the test bench we're going to be using,
which is going to be a more reasonable
test bench. It uses a 7700 X which I
would say is a more respectable CPU
compared to people going top of line
with a 9800 X3D. It's what somebody
probably would build a PC with either
one of these graphics cards with. We'll
talk about the entire test bench and
dive into some testing. To go over the
specs of the test bench, we have the
Ryzen
77y700X that is an 8 core 16 thread with
a large tower cooler cooling it. We also
have 32 gigs of DDR5 RAM at 6,000 MHz in
dual channel. This test bench is packed
with storage as well with a 4 TB Lexar
Gen 4 NVME SSD. We have an ASUS ROGstrex
B650 Wi-Fi motherboard. We have a 1200 W
80 plus gold fully modular power supply.
All inside of a pretty high airflow full
ATX case. So, now that we've shown you
guys our test bench, we're going to be
taking each of these GPUs, and we're
going to be loading a lot of games,
going back and forth to see exactly what
the FPS difference is on these two cards
at just a $50 price difference. Let's
get to gaming. All right, guys. We are
testing out this new AMD GPU on the
market here. And we're currently running
some 1440p ultra settings. I I I knew
those settings. I had it memorized. Um
I'm going to actually show you guys
settings here in a second. Once I end
this guy's career,
this guy is you. No way. There's no
shot. He just he looped. Oh, he thought
he was sneaky. You ain't real, fam. You
ain't real. All right, so you guys can
see here we got ultra. There he is. I
told you. Here he comes. That was ultra
settings at 1440p. No upscaling. I was
just confirming the fact I'm couch
freeze frame that. You just like I just
I'm thirsty for blood right now. What's
that? Oh, there he is. Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, somebody.
Why are they so fast? Yeah, you guys can
see we're we're getting um anywhere from
like 140 upwards of like 200 FPS at
times. So, it's definitely pretty solid,
especially with like no upscaling. And
the game looks really good, too. Yes,
sir. I know AMD definitely markets this
as being able to go for uh 4K if you
want to. Uh obviously that would involve
some upscaling as you'll see later on,
but uh I think this is a true 1440p like
ultra settings uh graphics card and
we'll see what the little brother the
979 XT does and how close it compares
depending on the pricing and
availability.
Whoa. There it goes. You kidding me?
You're kidding me. He's going to get
res. Oh wow. Guess what? Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, there's a person trailing.
Punch maiden.
Breathe on it. Is it the car 98K? I'm
going to die so quick with this thing.
No, I would say that that's pretty good.
1440p, no upscaling. We're getting 150
to 200 FPS. That's That's very solid for
this new AMD card so far. see how it
runs on the 9070. All right, we're
testing out the 9070 nonXT and we're
running the same settings, 1440p ultra,
no upscaling right now. This feels
pretty similar. Feels very similar. I
guess takes really long to reload.
Yeah, for for a little movie magic, uh
we are filming this after running all
the benchmarks before, so we'll be sure
to look at them side by side. Oop, side
by side before we do our conclusion, but
you guys are seeing what we may have
forgot. Definitely still just as
playable, though. I mean, I feel like if
I was in the market, um, and well,
assuming both cards you can actually
get, I would just take either one that I
could get.
[Music]
Armor
loaded the tracking.
Armor loaded. He would have been Michael
is down. Quit it. I swear if I kept if I
kept playing this game, I could have had
a chance at like some type of cool like
sniping thing. kind of thing like little
little phase stuff. See that? Yeah, we
hit those.
I just got I just got helicoptered. What
the heck? They
are. I'm done. I'm gone. He said he said
so much loot. It's insane. Oh, where did
they come from? Teaming. Teaming.
Holy aim assist.
Stop. Holy aim assist. Stop. Stop.
No. Oh. Oh, that they were low. Low.
This is how I serve my country. Yeah, I
serve. I'm second prestige.
Is that a ninja turtle? Why is there Why
is there two of you? I know. I'm not
playing duos right
[Music]
now. That was
Oh my god. There we go. That's it,
right? That's it. That was a long run,
but um I mean I got to see the side by
side because in all honesty, just
playing it did not feel any different
than the XT, but I'm sure it lost a few
FPS. Next game. All right, guys. We are
now on the 9070 XT with Spider-Man 2
running 1440p. Uh we should have no
upscaling whatsoever going on here. So,
no upscaling. We are running native. Um
wait, this needs to be off. This will
make it better. Here we go. Now we have
absolutely no upscaling going on here.
Uh very high settings 1440p and we are
looking pretty good. I mean getting 100
FPS. This game looks so good. So the
graphics are like the water even. Yeah,
this game looks so good at uh tracing.
Where's the rate tracing action? You do
have the ability to turn on RT which we
will experiment with a little bit here.
Um but I imagine if you are going to run
RT um I'll try the lower settings RT
here cuz the main thing that changes in
the game is the reflections on these
buildings. And there little stutter
right there. Not amazing, but we'll
stand in this spot right here and let's
try some RT. Let's Oh, it just went
straight to hide. You see how though
those buildings now you can see
everything that's happening on the
inside. It's compiling the shaders. This
might take a minute, but let it load in.
But yeah, now you can see all the
details inside all those buildings.
That's crazy.
I will say I'm normally like really anti
RT, but this is definitely one of the
games that you can actually see the
implementation of like the lighting and
everything. Like you can see all the
stuff behind you. Mhm. and everything.
So, it's kind of cool. It is compiling
shaders right now, so the performance
might be a little stuttery, but it's
actually handling RT pretty well. Um, so
this is pretty impressive for a new game
like this. You also have the ability to
do upscaling. I was going to test
upscaling, but if you're getting 100 FPS
realistically in these games, even if
you just get um 60 FPS, it's good.
getting 100 FPS, dips in the 90s every
so often. We'll run uh some FSR4, FSR3,
run FSR3 on quality, and we will we'll
just leave without frame gen. I mean,
yeah, we're up to the higher hundreds
now. It's probably like a 10 FPS
difference. Doesn't look too bad, but it
does help out, especially if you are
going to keep RT on. It does add a
little bit of graininess in the
distance, I see, but there's just so
much happening in this game texture-
wise. It's it's pretty crazy. But yeah,
9070 XT, this ain't too bad. This is
definitely playable. See if I can get a
uh a crime scene to pop up here so I can
actually do something instead of just
swinging around. Who are these people?
And there's just people. There's a fire
and there's people that caused it. Yep.
Hello.
Goodbye. You're getting about 80 FPS at
times. See if I can put these fire. I
didn't know webs put out fires
apparently.
I don't know if real life works like
that.
Nice. I know. You webbed their car. I
webbed their car. Hey, this is looking
really good. VRAM. Glad we got it. We're
up to 14 gigs of VRAM running some RT
here. So, the 16 is definitely useful.
Um 4K might be kind of tough, honestly.
Uh you would probably run into a
situation where uh you would have some
V-R limitations, but the only this is
just crazy just seeing inside every
single building. There's so many
buildings going here. So, yeah,
Spider-Man 2, great test. And this GPU
is performing very well. Let's see what
the uh little brother can do in this
game, the 9070, and see if uh especially
for the price difference. Uh which
actually, spoiler, right now recording
this, we don't know the price
difference. We'll probably know at the
beginning of the video. It'd be
interesting to see if getting the lesser
GPU would be worth it in a game like
this, or would there be too many
trade-offs. All right, guys. We are in
Spider-Man with the 9070 nonXT. And this
time, uh I know last time we launched
and turn RT on. I'm going to go and
start with RT on on very high settings,
1440p, no upscaling, using a high rate
tracing preset. And I think I'm starting
to see the difference a little bit. Um,
yeah, definitely a little bit. So, I
feel like the XT might be better for
these games at 1440p with rate tracing
on. And this one, I mean, we're getting
close to 60. Turn on FSR. We'll have no
problems getting 60. I mean, look, look
at my reflections here, guys.
Yes, definitely. It's playable. I mean,
we're doing a sky test at 100 FPS, but
it's one of those things where, yeah,
I'm starting to see the gap a little
bit, especially in that location I was
just at. We're getting more dips below
60, but still a good looking game. We're
going to continue as is right now. We'll
go ahead and run over to this
crime. There's some branding going on
over here. What are they
doing, y'all? Yeah, it's pretty bad,
isn't it? These guys have
flamethrowers. I'm about to
die. Yes. All right, let's get up here.
So, yeah, I would say definitely dips
into the 40s now, which is not what we
were getting before. And that was even
This is now with the shaders compiled.
Before we were kind of getting like
lesser performance because the shaders
weren't fully compiled. So, let's go
ahead and turn on some FSR and see if
there's a difference at all. See if it
helps out because I mean you got the FSR
tech. Might as well use it. See, the
whole biggest thing in this game is
swinging around. Will we get major dips?
Definitely getting a little below 60,
but we're not hitting the 40 mark like
we were before. Close, but we're not
right now. So, hey, FSR works out great.
I would probably say 9070. focus less on
ray tracing if you want to play games
like this or run lower details and you
can get 60 fps and have RT on.
Everything's so bright and dynamic. But
um yeah, Spider-Man, not bad. Good test
to see the difference between these two
GPUs. Let's move on to the next game.
All right, we are now testing out the
970 XT and Marvel Rivals. And I decided
to do no upscaling with this one. So,
we're 100% render res 1440p running the
medium preset, which does have a high in
there as well. And uh yeah, this is not
a game I normally recommend not using
upscaling honestly, but I know there's
those competitive players out there that
they refuse. So, we're doing it. Really
good. And yeah, this is a very it's a
very demanding esports title, which this
may be a direction that we're going to
start seeing all esports going. They're
just a lot harder to
They may just be harder to run. And
let's also kill some noobs while we're
at it. Yeah. Yeah. We're pretty much
like I would say comfortably maintaining
100 FPS. Yeah. It's like right on the
line. It didn't really have a whole lot
of fluctuation to it. No. All right,
team. Come on. Let's just let's let's
push this point up. I'm going to be
honest. We kind of suck. The cart. It's
literally still at the start of the
game. What are you doing?
97xt. Good. Team bad. Yeah, team bad,
team not great. All right. So, pretty
pretty much safe to say we maintain 100
FPS average. We never really moved from
the start, so couldn't really get you
much more results than that, but it
definitely did really good. 24 gigs of
RAM, guys. That's wild. See what the 970
can do. All right, guys. We are playing
Marvel Rivals once again on the 970 this
time. And uh you know, we are playing a
different map, different mode. And so,
so far, it does seem like this one's
actually doing a little bit better, but
I think that this is a smaller map with
less demanding properties. And if you
just take into fact all the other tests
we've done so far where you can see a
difference, it's definitely just the
variability of this game. So, not going
to be a perfect sideby-side test, but
hey, you at least get some gameplay on
this map with this card. It definitely
does go to show though that this, you
know, the XT versus the NXT aren't like
insanely different. Now, we're going to
we're going to play forwards a little
bit here.
Oh my goodness. Where my SPRS? Please go
get him, Squirrels. Come on. We got
this. She just ulted and killed her.
Yeah. Get Doctor Strange. Oh my god,
dude. Squirrel candy.
This is like cyber harassment. It kind
of is. Why are they?
We're back to where we started. I'm
pretty sure this is my old teammates.
Yep. They just kept playing and now
you're just destroying. No shot. You
just What if they just don't Okay. I was
like, what if they just don't turn
around here?
What did they do? Yeah, we'll have to
we'll have to do some sideby-side. Still
two different modes, but it was two
different maps we got to test. And I
don't know. This seemed pretty good for
at least Marvel Rival specifically. And
you're going to see that whenever we get
two close GPUs. There's going to be
times where they do sometimes not look
so different. Thanks game. All right,
guys. We're loading into the finals on
the 970 XT 1440p native. We're actually
running high rate tracing on the epic
preset, which is funny. RTX global
illumination. Nvidia. Oh, we'll see what
this AMD GPU can do. But this is again a
game that's not incredibly popular right
now, but it's another demanding
first-person shooter that'd be kind of
fun for you all to see. And um yeah, you
can give this game a go yourself if you
want to on your own PC. But I mean, I'm
pretty impressed with the the FPS so
far. And it looks
[Music]
good. I'm backing up.
Oh, I can't see anything that's
happening over there.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Get
closer. Couldn't visit. Okay.
Teammate,
help. Where did I spawn? I I got a kill
though. Nice. Something went through
that
door. Hey, there's the finals. It ran
good. I think we were pretty good. 110
plus FPS, sometimes down to the low
100s. Not too bad. Let's see what the
970 can do and see if it comes close to
the performance levels. All right, guys.
We are in Oh. Oh, wait a minute. Uh,
we're in the finals. Uh, currently
running the same settings, a little bit
of RT action, and I did join a game
mid-action. And I will say the FPS is a
little bit lower. We were in the
hundreds last time. Now we're in the
80s. The map is different though. So,
this might be like the opposite of what
we just saw in Marvel Rivals. We might
be on a more demanding map as
well, but this is still playable for
sure. And again, this is with RT. I
mean, most of you gamers, if you are
going to play this competitively, you
probably would turn RT
off this jump. Oh, no.
Oh, dang it. Surprise.
Oh, yeah. Run away. Run
away. Oh,
barrel. The same person, too. Yeah. Come
back here. No. This guy just loves to
fight me, doesn't he?
[Music]
Hey,
buddy. Oh. Oh, there's more ninja
stars. Into the green smoke. Oh god,
that's really bad.
You a I want to fight you.
Oh, okay. Maybe I don't. Whoa.
Dang. Sudden death. You guys control. Oh
my
god. And a unfortunate. Hey, the final
seemed like it was a decent amount more
demanding here. But that concludes all
our benchmark runs live testing style.
Let's do some uh sideby-side benchmarks
to easily compare these GPUs and
hopefully see some games that you all
like and maybe are considering picking
up one of these GPUs for and we'll come
to a conclusion on which one's the
better option. All right, guys. Now that
we finished our sideby-side benchmarks,
let's go ahead and dive some technical
tests to see which GPU makes the most
sense. Considering at MSRP, we're only
looking at a $50 difference. First up in
Blackmouth Wukong, we decided to really
push these things to their limits. So,
keep in mind the FPS numbers are going
to be a bit low here. But with the 9070
XT, we got an average of 28 FPS, a max
of 35, a minimum of 21. And with the
9070, we got an average of 24 FPS, a max
of 31, a minimum of 18. If you are going
to be running 1440p high settings with
any sort of rate tracing in a game like
Wukong, you're going to want to use FSR
to get at least 60 plus FPS on either of
these GPUs. So, do keep that in mind.
This is a worst case scenario for these
graphics cards in a very demanding game.
Next up is Cyberpunk 1440p ultra
settings, and we decided to turn off
rate tracing for this one. With the 9070
XC, we got an average of 143, a minimum
of 102, and a max of 180. With the 9070,
we got an average of 131 with a minimum
of 103, and a max of 161. This one has a
decent uplift in average FPS here, but
is it worth the $50 difference? You all
let me know down below. Next up, we have
a new game, Monster Hunter Wilds, 1440p
ultra settings with no upscaling. With
the 970 XT, we end up with an average of
94.34 FPS with a score of
32,019. And the RX970 got an average of
84.10 FPS with a score of
28,584. Once again, a 10 FPS difference.
And for 50 bucks, that seems worth it in
a game like this. and do have room for
FSR as well with some frame gen which
this game does recommend you'd use to
get 100 plus FPS consistently. Next up,
Indiana Jones in the Great Circle 1440p
high settings with no path tracing. We
are running native settings and I think
we are very CPU bound in this game with
the 7700X. So do take these numbers with
a grain of salt. This is a very CPU and
GPU bound game and I tried to keep a
very consistent path here so you guys
can see a sideby-side comparison. But
both of these are getting about 90 to
100 FPS, but you all be the judge at
home. Then we ran our 3D Mark Times by
score and with the 9070 XC we got a
score of
24,166 versus the 9070 with a score of
21,691. And then lastly, I decided to go
back and run Cyberpunk again at 4K
because AMD does advertise these as 4K
GPUs. While I will say if you are going
to run 4K, you're probably going to be
focused on 4K with FSR, not native 4K
gaming. But we decided to try it to see
what it can do. The 970 XC got an
average of 76 FPS, a minimum of 67, and
a max of 98. while the 970 got an
average of 52 with a minimum of 44 and a
max of 66. So hopefully you guys enjoyed
all these different benchmarks and uh
it's painted an interesting picture for
these two GPUs. So let's go and bring
Jackson back in here and wrap this whole
video real quick and give you our final
conclusions on both graphics cards. All
right guys, we just did a lot of
benchmarks and these cards both do
really well in 1440p and even a little
bit of 4K which Matt will talk about in
a minute. But it's pretty crazy to see
that that $50 price point really doesn't
have a major difference. So, it may come
down to which card can you actually get.
Of course, if you want a big three fan
chunky model and you're thinking about
doing 4K, obviously go with the XT,
especially if it really is only $50
more. But if you're having trouble
finding stock or god forbid they're
scalpers selling these cards, just get
the 9070. That's the biggest takeaway
here is honestly whichever card you can
get, if you are desperate for a graphics
card right now with this level of
performance, you should definitely pick
whatever one you can get up because the
price to performance is pretty solid
considering the market right now. And I
really think either one of these would
be a great option. 4K is possible on the
9070 XT. But realistically, if you're
going to want to have a great 4K gaming
experience, you are going to be using
upscaling. So, if you absolutely hate
upscaling, you're going to need to spend
a bit more money on a higherend GPU and
disable all that upscaling. But
honestly, that's kind of the future
right now. So, you might just have to
get used to that, especially with any
new GPU launch. But the 9070 is an
awesome 1440p GPU. And I really think
for both of these, 1440p is the sweet
spot. But if you do want to delve into
4K, 9070 XT. But if you want to stick
with 1440p, the 9070. But I want to hear
from you guys. Which one are you
considering picking up and if you do
manage to get one, we want to know what
inventory is like on launch day. Let us
know down below. Let us know especially
where you picked one up and what price
point cuz hopefully these stay close to
MSRP. But I do have a feeling they're
probably going to be a decent amount
more expensive. So as always, we hope
you guys enjoyed today's video. If you
did, make sure you check out our other
two YouTube channels and also our
twitch.tv/toastybros. And don't forget
to like, comment, and subscribe. And
we'll see you guys on the next one.
Bye-bye. Now, we know graphics cards can
be pretty hard to get. probably even at
the time of the release of this video.
So, make sure to check out pcb bros.te
because every so often we got a hidden
gem on there. PC bros.te. We sell gaming
PCs so you don't have to worry about
parting together each individual part to
make a PC build. And you have peace of
mind with a one-year warranty. And you
can also save some money using code
toasty Bros on checkout. You'll save 3%
your next purchase. See you guys later.
Goodbye.